Artificial Intelligence is one label for
it, but another label for it is just
forms of systems that evolve under
their own rules, in ways that might be
unexpected even to the creator of those
systems, that will be used in some way to
substitute for human agency in a lot of
instances; and that substitution for
human agency might be something that is
quite autonomy- enhancing for humans,
individually or in groups. If you have a
system that can worry about stuff that
you don't have to worry about anymore
you can turn your attention to other,
possibly more interesting or important
issues. On the other hand, if you're
consigning to a system agenda-setting
power, decision-making power, again either
individually or in a group, that may
really carry with it consequences that
people aren't so much keeping an eye on
it, or people who are directly affected
aren't in a position to keep an eye on it. I
think that's creating some of the
discomfort we see right now with the
pace at which AI is growing and
applications of machine learning and
other systems that can develop under
their own steam.
These are the sorts of things that give
us some pause. And I think about the
provision of government services, or
decisions that are uniquely often made by
governments, such as under what
circumstances somebody should get bail
and how much the bail should be set at,
whether somebody should be paroled from
prison,
how long should a sentence be? These are
things we usually consigned to human
actors— judges — but those judges are
subject to their own biases and
fallibilities and inconsistencies. And
there is now an opportunity to start
thinking about what would it mean — equal
protection under the law — to treat
similar people similarly? And machines
could either be quite helpful with that
in double-checking the way in which our
cohort of judges is behaving.
It could also be I think an unfortunate
example of "set it and forget it" and
biases could creep in, and often in
unexpected ways or circumstances that
really will require some form of
oversight. All of these systems
not only have their own outputs and
dependencies and people that they affect.
They may also be interacting with other
systems, and that can end up with
unexpected results and quite possibly
counter-intuitive ones. We have had for
many, many years for the functions in
society undertaken by professionals,
where the professionals are the most
empowered, able to really affect other
people's lives, we often have them
organized into a formal profession, even
with a guild that you need special
qualifications to join. There are
professional ethics independent of what
you agree to do for a customer or a
client. Now I don't know if AI is ready
for that. I don't know that we would want
to restrict somebody in a garage from
experimenting with some cool code and
neat data and doing things. At the same
time, when that data gets spun up and it
starts affecting millions or tens of
millions of people,
it's not clear that we still want it to
be as if it's just a cool project in a
garage. Interestingly the academia in huge
part gave us the internet, which in turn
has been the gift that keeps on giving;
and so many features of the way the
Internet was designed, and continues to
operate, reflect the values of academia
that have to do with an openness to
contribution from nearly anywhere, an
understanding that we should try things
out and have things sink or swim on
their reception, rather than trying to
handicap ahead of time what exactly is
going to work, tightly controlled by one
firm or a handful.
These are all reflected in the Internet,
and for AI, I think there's a similar
desire to be welcoming to as many
different ways of implementing and
refining a remarkable tool set that has
developed in just a few years, and the
corresponding reams of data that can be
used, and that in turn, can go from innocuous to quite sensitive in just one
flop. To be able to have academia not
just playing a meaningful role, but
central to these efforts, strikes me as
an important societal hedge against what
otherwise can be the propriatization of
some of the
best technologies, and our inability to
understand how they're doing what they
do, because often we don't know what we
don't know,
Able even to suggest design changes or
tweaks, and to then compare it rigorously
against some set of criteria that are
criteria that in turn can be debated
about what makes for a better society,
what is helping humanity,
what is respecting dignity and autonomy,
and those are questions that we may
never fully settle but we may have a
sense on the spectrum of which is
pushing things in
one direction or another. If we didn't
have academia playing a role,
it might just be a traditional private
arms race and we could find that "gosh
somehow this magic box does some cool
thing offered by name your company we
don't really know how it works and
because it's a robot it's never going to
quit his job and move to another company
and spread that knowledge or retire and
teach." These are the sorts of things that
over the medium to longer-term mean that
having a meaningful, open project that
really develops this next round of
technology in the kind of open manner in
which the internet was developed, and is
often healthily criticized and refined,
that's what we should be aiming for, for AI.